now it's a true pleasure not to announce
the final section of the symposium the
final three talks and a real finishing
up on a very high note real high caliber
of speakers in this last session that
are covering particularly global change
global change modeling for biodiversity
and first we'll start out with Rob
qur'anic with a leader in biodiversity
informatics well as Artemis to change
analysis it's also co instigator of the
map of light project that I talked about
yesterday and we're talking about the
new vast machine challenges and
solutions to documenting global
biodiversity anything thank you thank
you alter and my honest appreciation and
thanks to the yell Institute of
biospheric studies for extending the
invitation to come here and have a
chance to interact with some amazing
folks doing remarkable research working
in the policy domain what do i do today
is talk about some challenges it's going
to talk title here of documenting global
biodiversity as change and looking for
solutions and in some ways this talk
nicely dovetails and reinforces a lot of
the core messages that you've heard
throughout the last few hours and over
the last couple days but unlike those
other talks I focus more on on this talk
from the perspective of someone working
in the emerging area biodiversity
informatics and really what I hope that
I can convince you is that the
integration of informatics approaches
and working in a big data kind of
framework really does bridge nicely with
global change biology and moves us into
their arena bringing information and
computer sciences to bear on the key
challenges that we face in the ring that
we're working in and so you might wonder
about this provocative first couple
words in the slide here this this new
new vast machine
I refer to the new vast machine said it
as a as a riff on a book title called a
vast machine that details how
climatologist have effectively built
this machinery to approach global scale
monitoring ultimately forecasting and so
Paul Edwards who's the author of a vast
machine makes a set of excellent points
about this distinguishing what he refers
to as making global data from making
data global and so I want to just give
you a quote that kind of covers his view
on making global data and making data
global so making a global data and this
is a quote from the book is collecting
planetary data and standard forms
through interconnected networks to build
data images of global weather and
general circulation he contrast this to
making making dated global which is loud
and I getting a finger and his quote
here is that making data global is about
building complete coherent and
consistent global data sets from
incomplete inconsistent and
heterogeneous data sources and what I
really want to come to you here is this
transition point from work and
aggregating and pulling together now
data and information and knowledge and
then integrating it and creating these
final products that gets to this idea of
making data global and an essential
point i think that i want to bring home
again it's been mentioned so many times
during the course of the last couple
days is the idea of not just monitoring
and tracking from the recent past to the
present org or going forward in time and
watching the world change it really is
coming back to this key idea of
forecasting of being able to forecast
the velocities of change whether it's in
climatology or whether it's in
biodiversity sciences
so this requires us and if you think
about the the challenge of me of making
global data the challenge of making
global data is big compilation it's big
data challenges and ridiculously
remarkably header engineers so we have
all these questions we want to know
about about life in the planet and
what's happening to it we need to know
what data sources to pull and where
those data sources are how to compile
more of those but we really have
relation to biodiversity these key
challenges of looking at the genetic and
species and ecosystem level diversity we
need to pull those resources into one
spot so we had this image here where you
can think about molecular thought when
we have molecular data genes and genomes
coming in we have our species knowledge
that comes from the legacy literature
and describes our image of your
cataloguing and compilation of knowledge
about where species are found and what's
out there and then the ecological frame
the abiotic and biotic context that
pulls us all together because it's right
in the middle spot what we're trying to
do in the big compilation the big data
challenges that we face and of course we
have seen many examples and I already
effectively covered this in multiple
different ways just to remind you just
once more that we is absolutely not as
we know that our sisters are effectively
reaching a level of crisis we look at
some measures of population indices that
start off in 70 run to 2000 and and for
we can see that there's our rapid
declines and many of our systems and
freshwater systems in particular but
certainly impacts in terrestrial and
marine arenas and the earth biocapacity
its carrying capacity has been
effectively at this point exceeded by
our needs that we have as a species for
food and fuel and fiber and feed and
that means that that we're now at a
point where we're not able to replenish
our resources we're using up more than
we're gaining back over over time and
that leads to John Hofstra is a
remarkable talking points about resource
scarcity being a big driver of our
future as we have a increasing
population with increasing needs for
food and fuel and fiber and feed of
course during crisis events for example
a gulf coast oil spill we want to be
able to predict how
biodiversity and industries like seafood
industries would be impacted without the
resources available to compile that
knowledge and be able to act on it
quickly we're going to be at a point
where we don't know the outcomes not
only of constant and accelerating
changes but also doing these crises
events where we have major changes
happening to the environment and our are
unexpected so the challenge I mentioned
challenges and solutions i'm going to
cover some key challenges expand a
relatively wide range of where we are in
the biodiversity arena that brings up
just simply thinking about species
distribution data but also but a lot of
other key impediments there's lineage
shortfall which is well documented in
the literature we don't know we've
documented somewhere between one to ten
percent probably of the known species in
the planet so ninety percent of our
diversity is I'm still unknown it's been
out there for discovery and we have an
integrated mobile Boreas practice of
documenting that diversity Walter's
really nicely talked about the wall seen
shortfall that slide that shows the
knowledge gap between our remote sensing
data and data coming from species
distributions is really clear and so
that's a major shortfall we need to
cover I've made up a couple I made up my
own one shortfall that hasn't quite been
described in its called I'm calling the
Darwinian shortfall there is no
framework for assembly and integration
of our phylogenetic knowledge there's a
new project called open tree of life
that will get us further downstream to
building a global and comprehensive tree
or forest of trees but right now that
that that a framework is missing and
this is one that comes from Holger craft
it's called the Humboldt interior wall
and it really is that we lack a
comprehensive set of trait databases
those are beginning to be assembled and
put to put together but a lot of times
we're lacking a consistent metrology
instead of standards for making sense of
the large-scale trade data sources and
on the positive side on the negative
side both we are opening up our
pipelines wider and wider to Poland
dated help too
deal with these impediments but at the
same time we have what's going to be
doing a challenge which simply means
that as these pipelines continue widen
widen that rates are increasing by the
day and by the year if you think about
sequencing for example in particular
where the rate of sequencing is is anna
cost of sequencing is going down by
orders of magnitude each year well above
moore's laws threshold we have this
delusion of data coming towards us and
we don't always have the techniques and
the Prophet processing power and turn
those data into knowledge so what are
some of the solutions to these
impediments well one argument i'm going
to make us as someone who's really
bridged into information science and and
tries to find a balance point between
global change biology and information
science it so we need to have
repositories that can store this
information for the long term and this
data for the long term and to be able to
describe them all and it's very very
usable linkable and so some of the key
repositories that we have and we're
developing when it comes to tax on
concepts names and the meaning of names
we have things like catalog of life
worms and itís and AOL and GNA openings
architecture eol has named services and
there's the gif name usage bank on the
geography side the big one is map of
life rapid life right here is a really
one that assembles knowledge from a
bunch of different sources and pulls it
all together it's really a key place
where we're going to be building our
spatial biodiversity knowledge i'm going
to come to map a life in a little bit
and touch on that in ways of walter
didn't get a chance to cover entirely
during his presentation on with genes
and genomes we have things like GenBank
and sri base we have a new open tree of
life project we have the bar code of
life database and true base these are
all ways to compile a knowledge about
phylogeny isn't and hopefully have that
be part of the mix and biodiversity and
with phenotypes and traits we're
building those databases now whether
it's morph bank or this try traits
database or ways to describe the
phenotypes more effectively using new
approaches in nepal and ontological
approaches like venus cape and these are
all built around a key concept that paul
edwards and the vast machine talks about
at length standards
boring stuff the kind of the glue or the
infrastructure the plumbing that holds
us all together is having a way to have
interoperable discoverable data that you
can find that is represented in ways
that we understand how to do that
discovery and effectively and so
standards reduce data friction they
allow data to come together in ways that
build those build data that is global
and so the Natural History community in
particular has developed one standard of
this touchin of briefly called delrin
core a kind of an evocative image of the
idea of a dark or hearing in this
painting and dark aura is a standard
that currently pulls together 500
million species occurrence records in a
common format it allows them to be used
in aggregators like map of life and
there's also importantly a standard
publishing format for delrin court
records called the dark or archive that
is really useful if you're trying to a
gate records and pull them from from
this ground up perspective this bottom
of perspective of making on global data
where you really want to pull those
heterogeneous data sources together and
put them someplace where they can begin
to be used before we make we make data
global and so one example this is
virtnet I just want to cover this
briefly cuz it shows you what's happened
in just a very short period of time in
10 years in 1999 when the first networks
came online for serving vertebrate
biodiversity records let's was called
Manus the mammal networked information
system there are about six institutions
at a cost about fourteen thousand
dollars a year providing about a million
records by 2010 the number of vertebrate
biodiversity records that were being
served over networks was at a 171
institutions serving about 80 million
records with 52 institutions on a
waiting list one to become part of these
networks but not having we didn't have
the resources or the person power to
basically pull those those institutions
onto the network at a spiraling cost of
about two hundred thousand dollars a
year just to upkeep the networks so
virtnet which is a project that compiles
all these different networks
whether it's mammals or birds for
ordinance or hopes for her pet fish for
fish net is scaling down the cost
increasing the sistene scalability so
it's cheaper to sustain and scales
infinitely in terms of being able to
support the growing amount of data
coming into these networks and so by
2013 will have 223 institutions
providing about 100 million records at a
cost of about twelve thousand dollars
per year which is a remarkable decrease
because we are using an infrastructure
that is cheap and it works really well
and it's super scalable the idea being
that we have this door mcclure archive
data files that come from providers that
are in Darwin core format they're
harvested and created and put into a
single large CSV file these are
processed in a MapReduce framework which
is a big data framework for elastic
computing allow us to index these really
quickly and really effectively really
cheaply I'll put these into postgresql
databases that have mapping applications
for on top of them and they can be
immediately accessible via the cloud and
so this big data framework for taking a
lot of data we're talking about hundreds
of millions of records are making
available really effectively quickly and
cheaply is a big task that we face them
in moving forward and that goal of
making global data and of course we want
to find out the fitness for use and one
of the know the quality this data data
quality is so essential and often
neglected but the key thing is that
across this large network of up data
coming online in terms of integrating
aggregating and making interoperable
dado out there that's usable we have a
lot of errors in these data we can see
that about four percent of GBF records
contain at least one type of a number of
very very easy errors to find they're
really really simple ones that you can
just immediately check at the records
and say there's got to be a problem and
there are more subtle errors in these
records sets as well that need to be
flag and checked and many people talked
about the importance of flagging and
checking these errors but out of those
four percent of the records that have
like obvious like oh my gosh these are
clearly wrong about fifty four percent
of those who have one kind of problem
the coordinates the lat long coordinates
fall outside the country sorts of a
country that is
listed on the record and you can see
that there are a host cascading that
have very very simple errors like thirty
three percent of those errors are
basically no data being recorded as 00
location so if you plot your biff data
on a map you get a ton of Records and at
0 degrees latitude 0 degrees longitude
because they're recorded the zero zeros
instead of no no data and there's a
whole set of other other errors 8.1
percent orders transpositions I mean
very easy things to fix that will help
meet those data more usable down the
road and then all those data sources
that are now being linked up so we have
a projects like AOL on serving as a
score aggregators taking in data from
gif and from NCBI or all these other
sources that really allow the data to
propagate out from their silos from
their individual databases into this
broader world of linked data where
everything links up as effectively
brought together into a single context
but one thing you'll note is although
there's obviously remarkable progress in
building out these networks of networks
and interlinking these data sources and
there's a growing conservation of
biodiversity data and knowledge there
are a number of databases projects out
here that are just not linked up and
those are effectively at risk for not
being sustained very well into the
future there's a lot of resources and
allocation spent on building databases
that never last more than a few years
and so we'd love to see those those
resources brought into this network and
it's one reason why matha life can be
very powerful I think is that it serves
as a way of bringing in some of these
these databases and resources that are
kind of out there in no man's land so
how do we link all these gated together
believe it or not I have a facebook
friend I know that sounds remarkable oh
this is a fellow that I work with on
linked data projects called John deck um
and if you think about the fact that you
make friends on Facebook and you click a
link and you say this person is going to
be my friend you can imagine the fact
that you can draw graphs out that show
you friends and your list of friends out
here whether it's Tim white up over here
or anyone else and if you look at how
Facebook operates they basically have a
model an ontology-based on what's called
a friend of a friend approach where you
can kind of do six degrees of separation
you can follow friends all the way down
chain and track those those
relationships you can filter them based
on marriage status or gender statuses or
on
interconnections the reason I bring this
up is because you can take the same
approach to tracking data in a web
context by really thinking about that
model of tracking relationships over
over a sort of a set of friends but you
can think about tracking relationships
over sort of digital objects as pull off
from collecting events so if you got and
collect and you have specimens that you
bring back in and you photograph them
and you have metadata records regarding
where those were found and when they
were found and you look at the genomes
or gene sequences from these things it's
going to all they put into a tracking
system where you can begin to link those
up and then filter on characteristics
that you want whether it's filtering by
specimens or tissues or images or
sequences or whether it's filtering by
taxonomy and getting the records that
you want that are linked up in this vast
linked up web of data objects that are
out there that's how we're going to do
science in the future it's how are doing
it now everything we do is effectively
brought into a digital digital frame so
linking those resources up is really
really essential so linking
standardizing improving in integrating
data transitions us from this first part
of the talk which is simply about the
idea of making global data kind of
aggregate up from the bottom pulling it
all together and looking at how we can
begin to operate on that and that and
analyze it to making data global to
really doing something with those data
to integrate it and to make knowledge
what I argue is that we've been very
close to this all workshop symposium
this whole symposium we've kind of come
back to this core idea that somehow
there's a virtuous cycle we're going to
create new kinds of knowledge by
basically having initial kinds of
questions you can we better document the
distribution of organisms of the planet
we're going to have a set of
repositories are going to be growing and
growing as we digitize and create
standardized reviews or of these from
the dictation efforts we're gonna have
tools and applications services and
analytical methods is growing tool boxes
that link up these repositories and
tools and this will start to create a
cycle where we can link those all
together in this large world of data and
basically go from having these initial
research questions to new kinds of
research questions that integrate new
knowledge products and that kind of
creates what I'll call a virtuous
informatics cycle
you can loop through the cycle you can
create knowledge more quickly answer
questions more effectively that's really
important for what map of life and other
projects we're going to another work
we've heard about is that we're
increasing the scale of data one of the
other to turn it into knowledge more
effectively for decision-making for
policy for better science and this is a
kind of loop we're going to have to run
in the future if we we have to be in the
position of doing this that's the way
that science is already working in the
21st century it really is making not
only integrated did global but making
integrated knowledge global in a sense
that we have data repositories here that
then feed in and create new knowledge
that gets stored along with that
original data and data the models
iterate through that cycle so I wanted
to just to briefly come back to map the
life Walter brilliantly that's done on
much of what makes Mapple life work and
how it works I'm just going to cover
some of the parts and pieces that he
didn't get a chance to cover in full
detail it's clearly collaboratively
developed project and community in a
framework and platform for integrating
biogeographic knowledge and it's a means
to also generate and store much finer
modelled outputs but also I want to come
back to a key thing Mapple life is
really about people it's about working
collaboratively and collectively a
curatorial context as a curator I find
this really powerful it's a workbench
for users to perform individual model
integration as well as a mechanism to
contribute their own knowledge and make
maps better and importantly it's a tool
for discovery of biodiversity patterns
and we want to talk more about that I
think down the road about how not the
life is creating knowledge products that
are beyond just simply the distribution
pies but look at things like species
richness and patterns of turnover over
space and time and map of life is really
about data I don't know if you had a
chance to see this on Apple life when
you were exploring it on your own
hopefully you've all had a chance to do
that this is our data dashboard what it
shows you is that we have about 40 data
sets right now or growing that's
extensively pulling in data code is in
the audience and not as we speak but
pretty much we're growing the number of
updated thoughts were ingesting we
currently have about ninety thousand
species in map of life and we have about
15 million data records and really
importantly really importantly we are
really clear about providing attribution
and citation back to the original
providers the original providers have to
be told that they can immediately see
that their data is on Apple life they
have to be able to get reports and
knowledge generated from Apple let the
ha their data are being used it's going
to be critical for us to make the case
that you get value and you're going to
get continued value for making data
available in this kind of way mapple
life is about models already covered
this I'm just going to go right on just
say that that you saw the great ways
that we can begin to think about
modeling all these different data
sources and do all the heterogeneity but
I most importantly not of life really is
about people you've seen this slide
before but I want to just remind it
again we've got people working up here
on the producing data bring into an
apple life really working to help people
do that as a big part of the map of life
is all about and to gain credit for that
it brings that into a repository a
knowledge repository where you can do
things like overlay data do first level
integrations create model plots whether
it's binary threshold the maps showing
distributions or whether we're looking
at probabilistic assessments per pixel
over a range of attacks on and
importantly model uncertainty so we know
that we can report what we don't know
and also just want to point out again
importance of having work benches where
users can interact with these data and
other kinds of ancillary information to
basically create their own models and do
their own map alterations and very very
importantly the back end we have all
these different use cases for people who
want to come in and use these data
whether it's a mobile user generating a
localized species list while they're
going to a national park whether it's a
naturalist who wants habitat preference
data for attacks on or localized habitat
maps whether it's a land manager or
scientist these are all fed to these
these consumers down over here and then
of course we want to make those data
available to other knowledge generators
like encyclopedia of life we can access
these data and provide them back out to
their to their users integrate those
into the broader realm of data resources
out there it integrates really
brilliantly and beautifully with with
citizen science and one thing that I
made the slide a few days ago but
Zooniverse came up in conversations this
morning among some of the participants
and what I want to really drive home
here is that when it comes to citizen
science and integrating citizen science
into map of life we're talking about
basically people doing classification
tasks like checking data making sure
that the data are correct when we do
this the key thing that has been shown
by Zooniverse is really simple if you
want people to come and do tasks and
crowd-sourced ask the way to make that
work is to tell a compelling scientific
story I can think of no story more
scientifically compelling about our
planet than our impact how people can be
involved in helping to tell that story
by doing so educate people who otherwise
not had a chance to do it about the
importance of the mission of really
working to understand how our planets
being impacted by by our actions and
then also providing incentives and even
digital rewards badges it sounds really
really silly to us but it's been shown
again and again in the educational
literature that making reward systems
even digital objects they don't have to
be you know physical rewards they still
seem to affect the same part of your
brain that likes getting rewards so this
is how people play the silly games on
facebook but we think that that not
silly at all is providing people rewards
for basically involved in themselves in
the process of doing science whether
it's someone who does a lot of activity
across the globe on Apple life and gets
a Globetrotter badge or looks particular
in birds and gets a flock spotting badge
those are ways that we're going to be
able to incentivize and provide reward
systems that will get people to be
participatory in working on these kinds
of projects so what I want to do and I'm
almost closing in on what I want to
learn to talk about here I'm just going
to go for a couple more minutes I wanted
to tell you one thing what they're
really correctly said something
yesterday that a lot of our challenges
are sociological not technological
however if you go to mapping life org
and you were to wait 10 minutes for a
result to come back from
our application or any application you
would be frustrated and leave you would
not want to spend your time waiting for
results to come back so that there is a
technological imperative to basically
make the application work quickly and I
want to tell you a little bit about how
we've done that from an informatics
perspective mapple life as a front-end
that we leverage using google app engine
for indexing whole list of our taxa when
you search on that list you get results
a result relatively quickly from that
indexed list it goes out to a back-end
that includes post Postgres database and
a mapping on stack that is really quick
returning those results as tiles to your
browser and effectively that is a short
summary how it works and a little a
little more exploded or a expanded view
of how this works you have these
checklist and range it you can reach in
data sets and points coming in to the
staging area the points come through G
Biff and then get pulled in these get
put into a production so I that allows
access via an API there's actually a
caching system that has a gum allows us
to globally pull allows a different
areas in the world to be able to access
that catcher really quickly and
effectively that then cakes back out to
this API for access from other resources
or to a browser and that index so that
people can access the product it's a
very simple architecture but it actually
brings us into the frame of doing big
data and be going to support a lot of
very very very quick returns of results
to your browser so I want to enter here
by actually just coming back to where we
started the session Walter mentioned
we're talking about how to better
document forecast change well I want to
talk briefly about a project that I've
been involved in and actually Walter yet
some Brown McGill are also involved in
that Walter touch them very briefly that
pie is very very closer to an apple life
it really comes down to how we're going
to be able to do that for casting
process we talked at the beginning this
talk about that EW vast machine
and what I want to come at the end here
is is how we're going to begin to come
to the point of forecasting the big
thing I want to say is that we've got
tons of challenges here it's not an easy
area to be working but one simple way to
conceptualize what we can do as a
starting point is we can ask ourselves
what is the general trends that we're
seeing from the recent past to the
present do that calibration track those
trends over say a 40 or time frame and
then see if we can begin to use that
kind of calibration to allow us to track
changes into the future so they did
behind that is to actually do something
really quite difficult at the start
which is to create a set of
environmental data layers that range of
a 40 or timeframe that reflect daily or
monthly climatologist over 40 years so
we're creating for the globe one
kilometre skill resolution a set of
layers that reflect their knowledge
about climate over over the last 40
years to also when cover when one is
something that I think is really simple
but actually I've been profound and
because the niche model in literature
hasn't been done a whole lot is to
associate the the date of collection and
the location of collection to that point
of that stack of layer see the stack of
layers and you say well what moves us
collected or were the conditions
literally in that stack of layers and
that that date pulled out layer out and
take that record with the conditions of
the time of that collection a really
simple process but one that allows us to
be going to look at trends right so if
you have that that date for us you have
a thousand points for species and give a
thousand species you can begin link all
those up and look at temporal trends and
then one simple way to look at these
patterns and start making sense of them
is to basically model niches and
distributions over two different time
periods say from the 1970s from 90s and
then 1990s through the teens and then
you could also do this kind of look at
changes in environment and focal species
occurrences in reserve so it's a
velocity of change in climate and
reserve area what is the velocity of
change biodiversity for species in
reserve over that that time period one
of the important things about this
approach is that were you talking about
this change assessment method we're
talking about doing this over thousand
species not one or five or ten or a
hundred but literally where the data
allows us where we have enough records
over those two time periods to be going
to look at these patterns of change
where we have well documented species
but also running those as new data comes
in we expect the world to increase in
terms of data data making global data
and so we can more effectively take go
from making global data to making get
global by working on this this method as
it comes available so in a nutshell and
quickly and I'm almost done we have our
period one time from here with our
layers over those 20 years for
topography and land cover and
precipitation temperature we have period
2 over here over the 1990s with the
teens and we take observed occurrence
data over in that 20-year bin for a
particular tax on and we're able to use
that to do some modeling niche modeling
approaches we there's many different
ways to slice apply on on doing the
ditch modeling but we'll create a niche
assessment for that period one and four
period two we can look at the Delta we
can look at the species niche shift we
can do the same for range by looking at
the observed occurrence data for those
two timeframes and from that we can
begin to ask simple questions about for
tax on do we have a situation where
we're seeing changes in distribution but
no change in niche which we might think
about has since they came to climate
tracking or conversely you might see a
situation where we see a change in in
the niche but not in the distribution of
that the taxes on over those two time
periods or wait so you mix the patterns
and over thousands of species we can
begin to look at traits and other
characteristics other species to find
out if there are some explanatory
variables that allow us to look at what
we're seeing in terms of these different
patterns and so in summary I guess I'd
say that that mapple life is not simply
a static way of viewing the world it's
also one that involves looking at a
change and change analyses whether its
range persistence or loss or gain and
certainties about that and in a way that
brings us to the place where we started
which is that the pieces are in place
for a new vast machine I think you
completely transform how we monitor the
planet pulse with that thank you thanks
a lot drop we have time for one or two
questions victory Catherine please
come on a hybrid and that that's a great
question the initial assistance were
distributed for two reasons one is that
the museum community wanted to have a
level of control over the original data
which is absolutely one hundred percent
reasonable but over time is these
resources have proven their value so one
of the key stats like I love repeating
is that we're seeing about three million
hits hits a week data requests a week
for virtnet data so these are really
highly used resources as they've grown
the system has become very cumbersome in
a sense that every single one of those
distributed databases how to be up and
running for you to get the consistent
result returns from a database query so
if you went in one day and searched and
you came in another day in search do you
find different results depending on
who's up or who's down so what we've
done is we've created a system where
there are still wife connections between
those databases but there is a datastore
a catch of data so that if one provider
is down you can access that local data
instead as as an indexed copy of what
was online from that provider and that
provides a level of sanity in this kind
of rolling proliferating world of like
thousands of databases being connected
into the system it also allows us to do
things like actually report back
statistics more effectively to the
providers